hello and welcome to this episode of the
apogee action reader series
this demo is an extension of another
accelerated episode that covers the
implementation of client credentials
current type using apogee's built-in
oauth policies
I would highly recommend giving and
trying that out first
building on top of that sample will be
demonstrating how to limit the access of
the token generated using oauth 2.0
scopes
provide a way to limit the amount of
access that is granted to an access
token
now let's walk through the flow
The Client app requests an access token
to receive an access token the client
posts an API call to apigee with the
values for client ID and client secret
obtained from a registered developer app
and along with that we are also
providing the scope as well
in this example the scope is lead
apigee values segment credentials
if the credentials are valid apigee
returns an access token back to the
client if not an error is returned when
apigee generates an access token it will
assign the read scope to the generated
access token
now with a valid token the client tries
a get called to a protected resource
apigee when list the token and checks
the scope
and then since the request to the Target
resource and then forwards the response
back to the client app
now with the same access token the
client tries to perform a post call
apigee values the token though the token
is valid the read scope is not allowed
to perform a post operation hence apigee
rejects the call and returns a 403
response back to the client
now let's deploy the sample and see it
in action in order to run the sample
you'll need an apigee X instance
provisioned with access configured for
external traffic
as a user you'll need permissions to
deploy API proxies create API products
and register developers and applications
to deploy the sample you also need the
command line tools like gcloud unzip
curl JQ and npm
if you're using Google Cloud shell these
are already installed
we've also included a Google Cloud shell
tutorial which you may simply click to
quickly get started
foreign
now that you are in the cloud shell
environment you can follow the
step-by-step instructions on the right
hand side
first let's ensure we have an active gcp
account selected in the cloud shell
now let's next navigate to the
appropriate directory in the cloud shell
finally let's open the env.sh file and
update the environment properties here
like the project apigee host and apigee
environment
let's save the file
and Source the envir.ss file
click authorize
now that the prerequisites are complete
let's click Start
now the first thing we'll have to do is
run this script
now this script will basically deploy
the API proxies
two API products
a sample application along with a sample
developer
the script also tests that the
deployment and configuration was
successfully created and deployed
correctly this may take a few minutes
now that it's complete let's look at the
console log it clearly mentions all the
apigee artifacts are successfully
deployed this is a proxy URL a wrap
client ID with the read scope is here
secret with read scope planetary with
write scope and the secret with right
scope as well so we have two APA
products and apps created with two
different
app credentials and appropriate read and
write Scopes created as part of the
script
now let's first try the
read scope token with the credentials
that we've received earlier so let's
call this curl command
we've received a success you will see
that you have successfully accessed the
resource store secured by oauth2 now
similarly let's run another command with
a post call
you will see that we're getting a 403
response with the error message being
required scope as right
now let's try the same example with the
right scope oh let me copy this curl
command
and paste it here
it's a successful response similarly
let's copy the same command for the Post
call
with the right access token and let's
make a post call
that was successful as well now with
this we were able to generate two
different access tokens with two
different Scopes read and write and make
get and post calls to see appropriate
access limited depending on the type of
tokens being used
now with this we are done with our steps
so let's go and click next
now that we've completed this lab we can
actually go ahead and read this tutorial
and also clean up right so let's run
this command so this should go back and
clean up all the necessary artificial
debate at creating as part of the
earlier script I hope you found this
video useful you can subscribe to our
channel to see more videos in the apogee
actually editor series
if you have questions please visit the
apigee community thanks for watching